the Assumption very often is that you
have to sort of run the gauntlet of
hookup culture in order to find a
partner one of the things I advise in
the book which I'm told is a complete
crazy thing to advise is to hold off on
having sex for a few months in the first
few months of a relationship because
it's a good way of testing whether he's
serious about you it's a good way of not
being clouded by hormones if you're
trying to like vet a partner and I hear
from women I'm like what are you talking
about what kind of man is going to wait
three months to have sex a man that's
actually really into you I'd imagine but
it feels impossible it feels like if you
go out there on the daisy market and you
have that restriction applied you can't
compete well you can't compete you're
not going to get as many dates but the
point of dating isn't to get a date I
don't know what what the studies show
but I would argue that this isn't good
for men either and it doesn't make men
happy either because actually men also
feel discussed about hookup culture and
sex it might be like a bit of a status
boost and a temporary fleeting moment of
Joy or whatever but actually I don't
think in the long run that makes men
happy either